let's do a couple of problems where the
roots of the characteristic equation are
complex and just as a little bit of
review and we'll put here this up here
in the corner so that it's useful for us
we learned that if the roots of our
characteristic equation are
r is equal to lambda plus or minus mu i
that the general solution for our
differential equation is
y
is equal to
e to the lambda x
times
c one
with some constant cosine
of mu x
plus
c two
times
sine
of mu x
with that said let's do some problems so
let's see this first one it's that our
differential equation i'll do this one
in blue our differential equation is the
second derivative y prime prime
plus four
four y prime
plus
five
y is equal to zero and they actually
give us some initial conditions
so they say y of
zero
is equal to 1
and y prime of 0
y prime of 0
is equal to
0. so now we'll actually be able to
figure out a particular solution or the
particular solution for this
differential equation so let's write
down the characteristic equation so it's
r squared plus 4
r
plus
5 is equal to
zero
let's break out our quadratic formula
the roots of this are going to be
negative b so minus four
plus or minus the square root
of b squared so that's 16
minus 4
times a well that's 1 times 1 times c
times 5.
this goes out there all of that over 2
times a a is 1 so all that over 2
and see this simplifies this equals
minus 4
plus or minus
see
16 this is 20 right 4 times 1 times 5 is
20. so 16 minus 20 is minus 4
minus 4
over 2
and that equals
let's see this equals
minus 4
plus or minus 2 i right square root of
minus 4 is 2i
all of that over
2.
and so our roots
to the characteristic equation are
minus 2 just dividing both by 2
minus 2 plus or minus we could say i or
1i
right so if we wanted to do some pattern
match or if we just want to do it really
fast what's our lambda well our lambda
is just minus 2.
let me write that down
that's our lambda
and what's our mu
well mu is the coefficient on the i so
mu
is 1.
mu is equal to 1. and now we're ready to
write down our general solution so the
general solution to this differential
equation is
y
is equal to e to the lambda x well
lambda is minus 2
minus 2 x
times c1 cosine of mu x but mu is just
one so c1 cosine of x
plus
c2 sine of mu x when mu is one so sine
of x
fair enough now let's use our initial
conditions to find the particular
solution or a particular solution
so when x is zero y is equal to one so
y is equal to one when x is zero so one
is equal to let's substitute x is 0 here
so e to the minus 2 times 0 that's just
that's just 1. so this whole thing
becomes 1 so we can just ignore it it's
just 1 times this thing
so i'll write that down e to the 0 is 1
times c1 times cosine of 0
plus
c2 times sine of 0.
now what's sine of 0 sine of 0 is 0 so
this is this whole term is going to be
zero cosine of zero is one
so there we we already solved for c one
we get this this is one so one times c
one times one is equal to one
so we get our first coefficient c1 is
equal to one
now let's uh take the derivative of our
general solution and we can even
substitute c1 in here just so that we
have to stop writing c1 all the time and
we can solve for c2
so
right now we know that
our general solution is y
we could call this our pseudogeneral
solution because we already solved for
c1 y is equal to e to the minus 2x
times c one but we know that c one is
one so i'll write times cosine of x
plus
c two times sine of x
now let's take the derivative of this so
that we can use the second initial
condition
so y prime
is equal to we're going to do a little
bit of chain a product rule here so
what's the derivative of the first
expression
it is
e it's minus 2
e to the minus 2x and we multiply that
times the second expression cosine of x
plus c2
sine
of x
and then we add that to just the regular
first expression so plus
e to the minus 2x
times the derivative of the second
expression
so what's the derivative of cosine of x
it's minus sine of x
minus sine of x and then what's the
derivative of c2 sine of x well it's
plus c 2 cosine of x
cosine of x and let's see if we can do
any kind of any kind of simplification
here well actually the easiest way
instead of trying to simplify
algebraically everything let's just use
our initial condition
our initial condition is y prime of 0 is
equal to 0. let me write that down
the second initial condition is y prime
of 0 is equal to 0.
so y prime when x is equal to zero is
equal to zero
and let's just let's substitute x is
equal to zero to this thing we could
have simplified this more but let's not
worry about that right now
so when if x is zero
this is going to be one right e to the
zero e to the 0 is 1 so we're left with
just with minus 2
right minus 2 times e to the 0
times cosine of 0 that's 1
plus c 2 times sine of 0 sine of 0 is 0
so that's just 1 plus 0
plus e to the minus 2 times 0 that's
just 1
times minus sine of 0 sine of 0 is just
plus c2 times cosine of zero cosine of
zero is one so plus c2
that simplified things didn't it so
let's see we get zero
is equal to this is just one minus two
plus
c2
or we get c2
is equal to 2. i had to add 2 to both
sides c2 is equal to 2.
and then we have our particular solution
we have our particular solution i know
it's c2 is equal to 2
c1 is equal to 1. so actually let me
erase some of this just so that we can
go from our general solution to our
particular solution
let me erase some of this
so we had figured out you can remember
c1 is 1 and c2 is 2. that's easy to
memorize
so i'll just delete all of this
i'll write it nice and
big
so our particular solution given these
initial conditions were or are or is
y of x
is equal to
this was a general solution
e to the minus 2x
times we solved for c1 we got it equal
to 1 so we can just write cosine of x
and then we solved for c2 we figured out
that that was 2 plus
sine of x
and there you go we have our
our particular solution to this
sorry where did i write to this
differential equation with this and
these initial conditions and what's neat
is when we originally
kind of
proved this formula whenever you
originally showed this form we had all
of these eyes and we simplified we said
c2 it was a combination of some other
constant times some i's and we said oh
we don't know whether they're
imaginary or not so let's just merge
them into some constant but what's
interesting is this particular solution
has no eyes anywhere in it
and so
well that tells us a couple of neat
things one that um it you know you can
if we had kept this c2 in terms of some
multiple of eyes and our constants
actually would have had eyes and they
would have canceled out etc and it also
tells us that that this formula is
useful beyond
formulas that just involve imaginary
numbers for example this differential
equation i don't see an i anywhere here
i don't see an i anywhere here and i
don't see an i anywhere here
but given this differential equation to
get to the solution we had to use
imaginary numbers in between and i think
this is the first time if i if i'm
remembering all my playlists correctly
this is the first time that we used
imaginary numbers for something useful
we used it as an intermediary tool where
we got a real a real a non-imaginary
solution to a real problem a
non-imaginary problem but we used
imaginary numbers as a tool to solve it
so hopefully you found that slightly
interesting and i'll see you in the next
video